foreign
we sanctioned a serious country that
could hit back it is hit back it has
arguably caused us more disruption and
dislocation three heads of state in the
Western countries have had to have lost
their lost office since sanctions were
imposed Putin is nowhere near losing
office the whole thing is an absurdity
sanctions are about hurting usually poor
people by rich people they're extremely
regressive form of war and is the form
of War
um they are an immoral thing in my view
you should not use uh the the the the
starvation or the deprivation of poor
people in the country or for that matter
oligarchs in a country
um as a way of trying to change someone
else's government that you don't like
um you have I have to say to say it
yourself anyway why is it our
responsibility to change the government
that we happen not to like
um but that's a separate assume we could
discuss that later but the fact is
you've got a weapon which sounds good
makes you feel good uh um is is is is is
lends itself to media rhetoric about
devastating sanctions disruptive
sanctions we're ruining them the fact is
it never happens that way sanctions were
imposed then it did not in any sense
deter Putin and they were directly
intended to deter Putin
um the same happens now um with the
invasion
um I don't see anything in his actions
that's deterred him or restrained him or
changed his policy at all in the
slightest and the issue about sanctions
then is we know that Putin's not going
to change his mind he's riding a tiger
he can't get off this tiger now he's
taken his decision we all thought he
wouldn't actually we thought he would
build up pressure and like a school
bully and then back off when he got
something for it we didn't think he
would cross the line and I didn't think
he would cross the line because it's
such a manifestly stupid thing to do and
self-defeating but he did so we're in a
completely different situation as a
result of the 24th of February last year
and the point about it is he's not going
to change his mind but we're interested
in the people around him so the silly
the security apparatus around him the
ones he blames for everything that's
going wrong the intelligence people the
military and then this group of
oligarchs about 20 who were close and
another 10 or 15 or so who are in a sort
of an outer ring and it's those people
that were sort of interested in now
we're not going to persuade people like
Patricia who is even worse than Putin in
what he believes or more extreme than
put you know birdnikov these people are
the Putin clones as it were they've made
him into what he is now ideologically so
it's not them but the other people the
the the siloviki who keep finding that
they're losing their jobs they're
falling out of high Windows they've been
blamed for things and the oligarchs who
I mean the message to them and the
message of sanctions to them is as long
as this man remains your boss your
country's not going anywhere they're at
the oligars sitting in in Knightsbridge
are going to March into the Kremlin and
shoot him I mean the words you read
which are ludicrous
um uh anyway you know I read Owen
Matthew's book on this the idea that
when Putin goes is going to be better
um don't Bank on it I mean don't Bank on
it it means these guys
put in somebody else it's the next after
that you're going to kill each one
inside it may not be someone better in
that sense but it may be someone who
recognizes and can recognize the
invasionally I mean I do say what
business is it of you I mean you know
I'm I'm in favor of resisting the
Russian invasion of Ukraine and I go to
war on that basis but that's that's
military action likely to be effective
effective
sanctions are about us showing off
feeling good virtue signaling
um trying to say oh we've done something
even if it's the wrong thing to do
um I just don't buy into this if you're
going to do something which is that
aggressive as a tech particularly the
poor of a country in this fashion you
have to be bloody sure you're doing the
right thing and you're bloody sure it's
going to have the effect that you
incentive Infinity yeah if we're sending
weapons to Ukraine and would you agree
with which we should how would we
reconcile doing that with sending
components to Russia that go into their
weapons well because that's what not a
non-sanctions policy all right don't
send the components but that doesn't
that is the sanctions
it's almost trivial things and they get
the component from someone else and you
know they do I mean Improvement is how
much the Russia's got in the world
that's what you really proved
the podcast talks debates courses and
articles visit the Institute of Art and
ideas click the link on screen now to
IAI dot TV